okay some hot news vice published a
piece called what eating hot chilies
does to your body
do we ever have this you're the best
guest we could have to talk about this
spiciness is not technically a flavor
did you know that because you don't
taste it on your taste buds you
feel it in your pain receptors yeah you
do ouch and um capsaicin
i don't know how to say it capsicum
capsaicin
capsaicin is the thing i don't know how
to say it but i know what it is it's a
thing in the peppers that's hot
it causes the heat it kills bacteria in
the food and it can also help you digest
the heat in your meal
um i grew up eating nothing spicy sean
the spiciest thing i had was
ketchup as a child so it's like a flavor
that's evolved from me
what else does hot sauce do yeah you
know i i get tagged every single time
there's an article that's like spicy
chilies will make your life longer or
spicy chilis they're bad for your heart
every time one of these stories comes
out which feels like
every six weeks everyone's tagging me
and it's been like a roller coaster ride
because one story is good
the next one's this the next one's that
but when people approach me in the wild
the number one question they ask is like
how's your health are you doing okay
and uh because some of these are so hot
you think maybe they could cause some
damage but
there are countries in the world who
really
specialize in sauces and they're they
have better gut health right
is this true that's that's true drew so
that's what i always i look
at the the cultures where this is a part
of their everyday
diet and feel like well if if everyone's
doing good here if everyone's thriving i
think i'll be okay and i did go to a
doctor
last year and i was like hook me up to
everything every scan you can do every
test every this every that i've
i have a hot sauce talk show that i've
been doing for 14 seasons
i know i'm actually nervous about what
you're going to say tell us
everything don't worry drew cause like
they when she called me back she was
like
all of your numbers it's like you're an
olympic athlete or something they're
they're all
they're all just off the charts in a
great way so
anecdotally would seem that these sort
of hot sauce articles about it being
good for the health anecdotally for me
personally
those all seem to check out